[Aplausos]
eu fui pressionar you eu era assim
contou dentro de uma de uma prisão no
meu país durante eu mais ou menos nove
meses a a situação e o as imagens ou a
história está dentro da minha cabeça o
que acontecendo é o cinema numa numa
cadeia que era reservada de acolher 200
pessoas mas a colher com mais de 800 mil
pessoas numa cadeia uma prisão que não
tinha nem eletricidade nem água a água
som os carros que estava vendo com a
água da enchente
a comida era uma comida repetitiva
durante todo o tempo que eu passei
dentro da cadeia
a gente usava dentro do novo negócio
muito grande
não use a vaga lá dentro depois de
cozinha
cada um vem eles estão de cada um e todo
o tempo que eu estava lá dentro é a
mesma coisa então isso na áfrica tem
mosquito da malária
então condições da dentro você estando
medo não tem janelas mosquito a pessoa
era afetava muito nas doenças
então dentro da cadeia na áfrica se você
está dentro o pessoal do meu país e já é
tipo você já acabou com a sua vida
então botei dentro da cadeia não tem uma
pessoa que vai te defender
eu os encontrei eu fui e sou de uma
família uma família pobre
dentro dessa cadeia
se lembram eu perdi toda minha saúde
estava doente há algumas elementos que
vocês podem encontrar lá tomando a
salvar sua vida então falava acabou com
a minha vida acabou dentro dessa cadeia
porque não tinha nenhuma equipe nenhuma
esperança de sair nessa prisão porque
não tinha ninguém pra mim me tirar de
onde eu estava vendo as pessoas morrendo
dentro da cadeia
você monta pegar seu corpo vai ser bom
jogar onde a história acabou dando a sua
da cadeia
então aconteceu um dia antes decidiu e
vivei ou de morrer mas não contínuo
ficar dando aquela situação porque tudo
se fazer lá
vocês vão fazer toda a necessidade lá
perto e vocês porque vão tirar de novo
quando o policial então vamos brigar
você tira tudo vocês vão trabalhar então
era uma situação muito horrível que eu
talvez e dentro dessa cadeia acontecer
um dia já decidiu o que fazer do jeito
que vocês vêem lá estói então do dia o
passinho parte 1
uma parede mas a gente cria um incêndio
dentro da cadeia
o incêndio muito grande muito grande e
que uma parte por dentro da prisão
e aquela padre que todo mundo começou a
fugir em qualquer direção do da meia
noite fugiu à polícia do tiro e se você
pode na prisão você vai para um tio
com certeza muita gente morreram e
outros amigos se encontram lá até hoje
ninguém me achando 15 pontos
eu fugi com uma posição em cima de uma
montanha
naquela noite caindo até consegui salvar
minha aula naquele dia eu acho que muito
de vocês vão tentar nos perguntar por
que eu se encontra lá dentro da prisão
nem assim a própria vontade ou eu cometi
um crime matou uma pessoa
o vovô odom uma coisa não
eu se encontra dentro da prisão caso da
minha opinião política
o projeto que falam
produção eu sou formado fiz política se
essa política e eu tentei eu também
tenho de dar minha contribuição
politicamente falando exprime também
minha opinião no sentido de mudar as
coisas no país
eu era mesmo de um partido político
então o governo decidiu de o parar com a
atividade porque lá a liberdade de
expressão não existe a liberdade a
manifestação não existe você manifestar
então tem que se esperar
se você foi a pedido da polícia a
situação já acabou
o tempo só que morra desapareça então é
um risco de fazer política na áfrica
especialmente no com eu aceitei fazer
porque tava com pena não entendendo a
situação social e política
por isso cansa de fazer isso então o dia
o governo decidiu que fazer uma reflexão
depara com a actividade do partido com
aquela resistência dos membros da
computação da polícia e os adeptos
muita gente morreram e lá aprender as
pessoas e quando há tantas pessoas como
eu falei você entra numa prisão acabou
pra você
a situação de vocês já é quando se
encontra lá fora se sentindo uma
situação muito degradante da minha
situação da venda
aí eu fui na cidade e de lá eu decidir
sair porque foi no meu tio não vou
conseguir mais de ficar aqui
nem tudo o que houve então a polícia
procurando também as pessoas que fugiram
da prisão de uma pessoa pode denunciar
pode sair por sair daqui
aí ela falou como que ele tinha um pouco
de uma possibilidade disse o avô tem que
ser procurar um local aonde que eu possa
se sentir seguro
aí ele tentou pra mim achar um visto um
ano diferente baixado ele conseguiu na
embaixada do brasil
eu saí do brasil a razão que eu saí de
lá como refugiado quando eu cheguei aqui
e me encaminharam no ombro que está aqui
chamado career cáritas
aí eu tive que a minha situação como
refugiado o que aconteceu ela me ajudava
e para me tentar de os integrar na
sociedade brasileira
o que eu não falava assim portuguesa e e
aprende português e aí tentar
desenvolver então eram sim para me
tentar desempenhar na sociedade
brasileira que uma sociedade que é
totalmente diferente de culturalmente
falando e racialmente uma coisa é uma
coisa diferente então conseguiu um
documento provisório conseguir a
carteira e depois de conseguir um
emprego
então se eu sei que nesse ponto aqui eu
vou tentar vou explicar o que é que eu
vivia tô vivendo aqui no brasil como
refugiado como africano como nêgo coisa
eu muito complicado às vezes mas não
está porque eu nunca vi essas coisas que
eu vivo aqui no brasil você tem que ser
um pra mim vocês nós vivemos num país
nêgo todo mundo é pego branco é
realmente pra você comprou então aqui eu
vim contar quase todo mundo sombrio e eu
misturado
então a língua diferente da cultura
diferente eu venho com minhas coisas
conseguir emprego
trabalhou no hotel e de lá que tudo
começou
eu comecei a entender com e compreender
algumas coisas dentro do hotel
o eterna discriminação isso que vou
falar porque eu sou sou formado dentro
de entender as coisas definido cada
coisa eu encontrar muitas coisas que até
hoje me choca quando a gente geralmente
é o inter já quando se chamado africano
do refugiado tem uma conotação negativa
aqui no brasil significa uma pessoa nem
uma pessoa que sair para pedir um
refúgio encontrar um lugar do da paz mas
é uma pessoa que a vida quase acabou
para ele não tem mais esperança viva
aqui procurar não ser fugir à miséria
uma situação catastrófica para que isso
mais ou menos a concepção
isso é provado porque fumava e um
refletor comia com os amigos as
perguntas que ele estava me perguntando
eu não estava entendendo isso mas depois
que eu entendi vocês lá na frente vamos
passar fome
áfrica do sul mas está começando a ser
muito lá na áfrica você não comia tinha
se refugiado tinha city essa eu não
sabia estava respondendo isso não deverá
funcionar temos empresas que fazem não
ter comida até o senhor acha pergunta
começou aí assumindo você na tv o ônibus
você ainda tem assim é o tablet xoom
você parece um militar você fugir lá fez
um crime você vai de novo eu sei naquele
emprego na assembléia uma introdução fui
no emprego
sei que naquele emprego é a primeira vez
que eu fui um colega banco me chamou de
macaco
me chamou de macaco duas vezes rindo
aconteceu no japão que trabalha no
restaurante os amigos a comendo eu
estava no meu canto comendo um ele
estava todo mundo aí acabam de comer me
chamavam com cortesia o perfil não sei o
que é uma postura e por isso você pode
tirar esse papo da gente eu assustei
como que você acha que comeram eu como
todo com cada um como pega costa de
tê-la então nunca vão entender essas
coisas não tira no nono posto
o meu chefe quando eu trabalhava tudo o
que era trabalho pesada era é o que tem
que fazer isso tudo que era tarefa
pesada vai jogar lixo a fazer as coisa
pensada
então não estava entendendo essa puc
até que um amigo falou comigo penso você
tem muita sorte de trabalhar aqui porque
era um lugar do pessoal muito dos
milionários
você pensou se mantém sua ajuda a
avaliar a relação de que um restaurante
aqui nesse lugar você não podia se
encontrar aqui não
isso me chocou bastante e chocou
bastante estamos sentindo minha
capacidade intelectual mas enfim dá
conta ele falava comigo você não é
inteligência inteligente você espero que
vocês conseguiram fugir na áfrica para
que você é uma pessoa esperta mas você
não é inteligente
então isso tudo todos elementos é um
juntei entende que não está fácil
eu estava escutando g
hoje eu sou uma forma geral
os imigrantes refugiados especialmente
os africanos não sou bem recebido em
relação de novo sorriso em relação do
nosso papel
eu posso falar em vocês disse a
qualidade que os de contar até hoje seu
sentado em um ônibus se hoje a última
opção de uma pessoa por cento ao meu
lado
a última opção um negro e é difícil ver
eu já dei conta disso sinceramente
todo mundo pode ter um espaço lá até
aqui mas vai olhar todo mundo me olha
vai dar outro velho olhava preferi ficar
em pé mas tem um lugar
não sei se tudo porque isso é uma
concepção um preconceito que eu não sei
então se estou aqui também queria pegar
essa oportunidade tentar passar uma
mensagem em vocês
eu só aqui como refugiado tô vendo um
país pobre seu site da banda nem minha
família nem pra que eu não conhecia aqui
ninguém só que sozinho é uma situação
que obrigou de sair mas quando eu sei do
meu país para chegar aqui é o tinha uma
capacidade uma competência
hoje em dia do jeito que ele falou sou
professor de inglês
os alunos são os advogados o médico
então queria falar
todo mundo nesse mundo tem uma
capacidade
todo mundo tem uma coisa tático lá todo
mundo é importante nesse mundo em
relação do papel do origem dele
hoje em dia eu tô tentando de contribuir
no desenvolvimento do brasil ajudando as
pessoas trabalhando mas só refugiado
então esse concepção de pensar que não é
pessoa que está saindo da áfrica
especialmente os negros seja os negros
aqui uma coisa
esse é o que tem pessoas que não têm
capacidade de suportar essas coisas e se
afasta
é muito de refugiado aqui não consegue
fazer uma integração caso desse
comportamento que aconteça você ficar
nos africano verde na rua você me dá um
me perguntar nada dizer eu tava morrendo
com um morro com
o 11 brasileiro eu saindo ele não estava
sabendo aonde estava indo um dia ele me
falou você vende bt
além de me pergunta saber se você vai ou
não ser que você faz na sua vida
tira uma conclusão a que eu sou um
camelo me faz me chamou de o melhor você
é um camelô vende humberto
eu nunca vendi bem porque ele já tinha
pensamento negativo além de conhecer a
pessoa
então além da gente se focar nesse
aspecto físico o do reino morrido de uma
pessoa é bom se focar na competência na
capacidade numa coisa particular com uma
pessoa pode trazê que pode mudar também
a sociedade
isso é muito importante isso vai ajudar
também pessoa que se chama refugiado se
sente à vontade
então se esses comportamentos continuam
pensando em estar zero vem aqui pedir
fugir fome morava lá pensando as coisas
além de se informar
isso é uma coisa muito errada que tem
que mudar nesse ciclo aqui 2011 vem
bnsf pensamento da gente tem que mudar
já que as pessoas têm que se abrir no
mundo entender que hoje tem movimento
das pessoas em relação da situação em
movimento econômica tem movimento social
é movimento política da guerra da terra
está seca
somos muda então não precisa dele de
ficar
[Música]
tony pipo é fã dele está indo muito
longe daquele país
é normal é uma situação que obrigou a
chance de chegar aqui então esse
preconceito acho que é uma mensagem que
eu vou passar você pode passar também
não posso pessoas
todo mundo se mais tempo pessoa que
tenha todo mundo tem capacidade precisa
da ajuda precisam de dar carinho de
conhece ele integrar na sociedade com
todo mundo porque o sentimento de vocês
um sentimento você não vai gostar uma
pessoa que diminuir o que falar as
coisas que você não gosta inclusive
porque sou um ano seja meu origem seja
meus contatos aqui mas só um ano
eu tenho direito de sentir o que todo
mundo sente
eis que era melhor minha contribuição
minha formação em relação disso e
agradeço vocês tudo com essa
oportunidade que me deram
meu nome é prince jeito que falam eu sou
professor
eu trabalho também no hotel aqui no rio
de janeiro
muito obrigado pra me dar essa
oportunidade
[Aplausos]